if Comic Cons anything to go by and
people really love Loki what do you
think it is about Loki that people seem
to really love kind of moreover Thor
whoa whoa whoa whoa several more years
of brother least therapy to follow yeah
you know don t what I love a bit look we
even talked about this all morning it's
really hard to you have a go as well but
I think I don't know that it was ever
the plan to have Loki in this many
filmed but purely to do with everything
that Tom brought to the table in the
first one and how incredible he was and
the the mixture of of strength and
villainous and mischief and and
vulnerability which is such an access
point you can immediately kind of
empathize with this misunderstood guy is
why he was kept you know if my correct
Kevin why he kept bringing him back into
every film like I don't know that was
ever the plan but I mean my hat goes off
to Talman and I think he's done such an
incredible job in every film and
hopefully we can keep sneaking him in
more forcefully I Love You Man I you
know I wanted to say in response to the
second bite
I think Loki is defined by Thor he's
defined in opposition to him that they
are yin and yang they are the sort of
the Sun in the moon that the whole point
of them is that they are in opposition
and the whole sort of firm I don't know
that the popularity of the characters
been such an amazing surprise I'd never
expected it in my wildest dreams and I
don't know I found him a fascinating
prospect because he's a mixture of of
playfulness and Tom and mischief that's
his moniker he's the god of mischief so
there's a playfulness to him but he's
such a broken a broken character he's
grief-stricken and bitter jealous and
angry and lonely
crowd and send a cocktail of all of his
kind of psychological damage and and his
playfulness as an actor is just a really
interesting thing to inhabit and by the
way you are the only Thor
you